[Música]
bienvenidos a europa hoy el programa de
actualidad europea de france 24 en
español yo soy estará claro desde el
parlamento europeo bruselas es un placer
saludarles en el programa de hoy
abordamos la situación y las relaciones
económicas y también comerciales en la
unión europea hemos visto acuerdos
comerciales varios entre ellos por
ejemplo con los países de mercosur
recientemente se ha firmado uno con la
nueva zelanda queremos abordar
exactamente qué es lo que ocurre con
estas relaciones comerciales antes de
pasar al debate vemos cuáles son las
relaciones comerciales en la unión
europea en plena guerra de ucrania en la
unión europea quiere lanzar nuevos
acuerdos comerciales con distintos
países para afianzar sus relaciones el
último pacto en firmar se fue con nueva
zelanda con el que la unión europea
refuerza su interés por la región indo
pacífica los 27 han intentado
revitalizar sus relaciones comerciales
en los últimos años ante el fracaso del
acuerdo con eeuu que se dio por
enterrado al llegar tan al tromba la
casa blanca la unión europea cerró
varios acuerdos históricos con canadá
japón y en 2019 con los países del
mercosur después de 20 años de difíciles
negociaciones sin embargo el convenio no
se ha podido ratificar debido al rechazo
del parlamento europeo a la política
climática del gobierno de chaín
bolsonaro en brasil y la deforestación
del amazonas
tampoco se ha ratificado por el momento
el acuerdo de inversiones con china
cerrado en 2020 congelado por la
eurocámara desde que beijing impusiera
sanciones contra eurodiputados la unión
europea considera que el gigante
asiático no está cumpliendo con lo
pactado no obstante con la invasión de
rusia las relaciones entre europa y
virgin tampoco han mejorado y no hay
esperanzas de que se desbloquee el
acuerdo y para analizar un poco las
relaciones comerciales de la unión
europea contamos con los otros diputados
y más rodríguez piñero del grupo
socialdemócrata bienvenida y más y más
gracias encantada de estar aquí
igualmente con el eurodiputado del grupo
renovar europa jordi cañas
gracias a ambos en los últimos años
hemos visto un impulso en las relaciones
comerciales de la unión europea ahora
con la guerra en ucrania la necesidad
que tiene la unión europea de buscar
proveedores de combustibles posibles
pero también también otros productos
para dejar de depender de rusia se puede
reforzar ahora el espíritu comercial
bueno yo creo que esta legislatura no ha
sido precisamente la que ha impulsado
los acuerdos comerciales esta es la
legislatura desgraciadamente es aquella
que ha congelado los acuerdos
comerciales los acuerdos comerciales
tuvieron un gran impulso con la comisión
anterior especialmente
liderada por la área de comercio asia
malström pero en esta legislatura lejos
de continuar esa estrategia de potenciar
los seguros comerciales basados en
normas con terceros países o con
terceros porque regionales de hecho lo
que ha sido lo que ha hecho ha sido
rebajar y congelar en algunos casos los
procesos de firma y ratificación ahora
tenemos pendientes ahora mismo de los
pendientes la ratificación de los
acuerdos con
con méxico chile sur se ha finalizado
después de tres años un acuerdo con
nueva zelanda y se había congelado desde
australia yo para que nos situemos había
congelado en los tarde a raíz de la del
debate club acerca de la compra de
submarinos nucleares
australianos y el enfado que tuvo eso
francia y por derivación en el consejo
por lo tanto está ésta está esta
comisión que era la comisión geopolítica
que tenía que haber utilizado los
acuerdos de asociación como un
instrumento geopolítico global ha sido
aquella que menos nos ha utilizado y
para acabar como tú bien decías yo creo
que la realidad lo que ha pasado los dos
de la hobbit y las de la gran ucrania
nos ha puesto delante un espejo europa
necesita
ser resiliente y para eso necesita
aumentar sus relaciones comerciales no
puede depender sólo del gas ruso no
puede depender sólo de la importación de
algunos productos de china sino que
tiene que ser capaz de diversificar sus
importaciones tener otros socios
comerciales preferentes y tener también
recupera algunas de las producciones que
europa necesidad para ser realmente
soberana a nivel estratégico a nivel
geopolítico y jordi estaba comentando
ahora este acuerdo comercial que se está
negociando con australia también se ha
cerrado también un acuerdo recientemente
ahora con nueva zelanda es esta la
región en la que debería ahora centrarse
la unión europea la del indo pacífico
que están también importante y
estratégica bueno yo creo que
precisamente como consecuencia de la
invasión de rusia por ucrania se pone
más de manifiesto que nunca la
importancia de tener acuerdos estables y
sólidos con socios fiables y que son
tiene una forma de entender las
relaciones económicas y comerciales
parecidas a las nuestras
sin duda alguna la unión europea tiene
que tener una posición estratégica en la
región indo pacífico pero es fundamental
que la tenga en latinoamérica el no
haberlo tenido ha dejado paso a que
china ocupe todo ese espacio de hecho
hemos dejado el ser el segundo socio
comercial para región ahora lo es china
hemos pasado un tercer lugar antes
hacías mención al acuerdo con mercosur
solamente pensar en un acuerdo comercial
con mercosur estamos hablando de que
representaría la cuarta parte del pib
mundial y de la población con lo cual de
una importancia estratégica enorme para
ello una cosa que quería decir estando
de acuerdo a lo que ha dicho jordi
incidir en porque se ha producido esto
porque esta primera mitad de la
legislatura las negociaciones de los
acuerdos comerciales han quedado
ralentizadas
yo creo que obedece a dos razones una
había también que poner en valor y
desarrollar instrumentos de autonomía
estratégica para establecer unas reglas
del juego equilibradas con terceros
países en eso estábamos muy mal
posicionados en instrumentos de defensa
comercial y se ha hecho el instrumento
que acabamos de aprobar
las subvenciones extranjeras de
controlarlo el control de inversiones el
mecanismo de contratación pública
internacional instrumento anti cuestión
se ha centrado mucho en dotarnos de
instrumentos en el que no estábamos bien
posicionados para tener que forzar unas
reglas del juego equilibradas y sobre
todo pensando en nuestras relaciones con
china y la otra razón creo que también
tenerlo en cuenta ha sido el cob ir
porque las negociaciones comerciales la
presencia es fundamental en todas las
relaciones no y luego es verdad que la
presidencia francesa es absolutamente
proteccionista y dijo él cumplió que
bajo su presidencia no saldría ningún
acuerdo comercial afortunadamente ha
sido terminar la presidencia y ya
tenemos el acuerdo de nueva zelanda
esperemos que pronto tengamos aquí chile
méxico y que mercosur pueda ser una
realidad sí muy importante hablar ahora
mismo de justamente el acuerdo con
mercosur
jordi fuiste además ponente del informe
sobre mercosur aquí en el parlamento
europeo hay alguna esperanza de que se
pueda ratificar
quizás con una victoria de lula da silva
en brasil yo no soy mucho de esperanzas
yo lo que creo es que es una necesidad
es decir firmamos acuerdos comerciales y
de asociación política porque los
necesitamos esto no es una cuestión de
esperar esto es una cuestión de donde no
haya donde no haya
bar virtud hay interés
yo creo que estos acuerdos tienen que
firmar porque tenemos que tener socios
estratégicos globales en los cuales el
comercio es uno de nuestras
interrelaciones
pero aquellos que no vean la virtud
porque crean que hay que centrarse en
áfrica hay que centrarse en la región
del pacífico como si europa no fuera
capaz de hacerlo todo un actor global
tiene que tener intereses y estrategias
en todas las zonas del mundo el lindo
pacífico por supuesto en áfrica por
supuesto pero en américa latina también
mire
hemos hemos firmado un acuerdo con
ovación a no hacer nada tiene 5 millones
de habitantes
sabes cuántos habitantes tienen mercosur
293 sabes dónde están los consumidores
de los productos europeos
el mercosur
entonces yo
creo que tenemos la oportunidad de
ratificar ese acuerdo en esta
legislatura y tenemos la obligación
porque porque si no perderemos una
oportunidad histórica mira el acuerdo
con mercosur como el resto de vuelos
comerciales yo también comparto muchas
cosas con inmaculada
realmente el tema la cobrita ha sido un
tema relativo porque los acuerdos
estaban en el caso de chile caso de
méxico está patente finalizados el caso
de mercosur estaba finalizado totalmente
y el mercosur se firmó la parte política
en el 19 la parte comercial de
comercialización de la parte política en
el pecho junio de 19 junio el 20
entonces están terminados ahí y para
hablar claro y como estamos en france 24
el acuerdo de mercosur no ha iniciado el
proceso de ratificación porque el
presidente macro que es un grupo liberal
hizo de ese acuerdo una bandera política
en política nacional
escribiendo el tema medioambiental el
tema medioambiental el único entonces yo
considero que el abuelo mercosur puede
ser mejorado
pero un acuerdo de asociación no es el
final es el principio y ahora mismo
tenemos un problema con mercosur que
tenemos una china que está entrando y
ocupando el espacio que estamos
abandonando y el espacio de china no lo
vamos a recuperar cuando tenemos un
instrumento que es de los de los
acuerdos más modernos firmados que nos
vincula directamente en temas tan
importantes como derechos humanos como
el tema de organización internacional
del trabajo convenios y el tema
medioambiental donde se donde se
garantiza el cumplimiento de seguros de
parís y si el problema es un problema
político nosotros como políticos tenemos
que pensar que no firmamos acuerdos con
gobiernos yo no fuimos en acuerdo con la
gas con lula da silva ni con señor
bolsonaro si hubo un acuerdo con brasil
con una nación que es clave en el futuro
clave en cuanto a que nos ofrece un
mercado maduro para nuestros productos
clave porque es clave en la lucha contra
la deforestación y el medio y el cambio
lógico cambio climático y porque tenemos
que tener instrumentos europa no puede
carecer de instrumentos en un contexto
de más de 300 de 300 millones de
habitantes porque es necesario
ante las dudas que puedes suscribir el
acuerdo al mercosur no con los
agricultores hay que también explicarle
al resto de trabajadores al resto de la
estructura económica de europa europa
necesita mercados alternativos para sus
productos que tienen un problema ahora
que necesitan mercados alternativos
porque tenemos que vender los productos
a alguien y lo que no podemos hacernos
es ponerlos a ponernos palos en las
ruedas porque nuestros trabajadores
necesitan empleos porque nuestras
empresas necesitan mercados porque
tenemos que garantizar cumplir todos los
acuerdos para sí tenemos que garantizar
sí pero también tenemos que ofrecer
mercados a estas empresas porque tenemos
que garantizar el empleo el crecimiento
para garantizar prosperidad y eso
también hay que explicarlo explicar que
no ratificará acuerdos que no impulsan
acuerdos basados en normas en
compromisos comunes eso afecta también
al empleo cuando tú vendes cuando yo
analiza la estructura económica de
francia
cuál es el sector industrial qué
importancia que el sector industrial que
pueda decir qué parte tiene el sector de
exportación
y qué pasa cuando nos vemos de acuerdo
con un mercado tan importante como el de
menos
les podría ser posible quizás reabrirlo
jordi comentaba que quizás podría
mejorarse y más a ver yo sí que entiendo
las razones y comparto mucho lo que ha
dicho jordi no pero al final tú firmas
un acuerdo con un presidente de un
gobierno no es abstracto la firma de la
firma la representan personas e influye
mucho que en esté al frente de un
gobierno y de hecho yo no veo posible a
que convulsionaron pueda tener lugar una
firma de un acuerdo con mercosur porque
no es fiable y porque sus prioridades no
son las prioridades y el acuerdo con
mercosur
requiere también
acompañamientos que nos garanticen que
los compromisos se puedan cumplir en
materia de desarrollo sostenible es
fundamental el tema de la reserva de la
biósfera de la lucha contra la
deforestación y el cumplimiento de las
normas laborales y ahí es que no está
comprometido bolsonaro entonces yo creo
que sí que influye
gracias y mayor di la menta blemente nos
hemos quedado sin tiempo
volveremos otra vez a este tema tan
interesante a ustedes les esperamos en
el próximo programa de europa hoy
gracias por ver france24 en español